Speaker 1: Real quick. Let's go to Aubrey from
Wisconsin. Many said do not speak to Aubrey
again on the show, but I'm just I'm tempted to
hear what Aubrey has to say. Aubrey, I don't
have a ton of time, but what's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Well, that is so this was about all I
could do to do. Okay. Real quick, the first
thing you said is like, I was practicing, like,
on YouTube because he made a production
and production, so the best. Anyways,
I wanted to know your opinion on that
settlement that Fox News came up with with, like
the Dominion. Do you think they're going
to stop like, you know, absolutely lying?
No. Is like Tucker Carlson going to be like,
hey, I'm still like an entertainer. So like,
I could say, whatever that show's net.
Speaker 1: I want to absolutely listen. AUBREY
it's not only that the settlement between Dominion
and Fox doesn't even require Fox to apologize
or say anything on air. In a written statement,
they said, Yeah, the stuff we aired wasn't true.
They're not even going to take it back on air.
And so Tucker is going to keep doing his thing.
They'll talk about Hunter Biden. They'll talk
about, you know, low birthrates with Elon Musk
or whatever else they want. It is. It's not.
Is Fox going to stop lying? Now is a hilarious
question. No, they are not going to stop lying.
Speaker 3: Car. Yeah. So they're never going to
admit that they were just a clowns. Okay,
cool. Real quick, I'm completely offended
that people said don't talk to me anymore, but I
do appreciate it. You are on our side. So I feel
like we get Andrew's.
Speaker 1: Wait,
I'm a what? What was that? I'm an area side.
Speaker 3: So you're an Aquarius and I'm a Libra
Rising. So, like, we get each other's energies
in that way, and I really appreciate that, But
you're kind of the weird arrow sign, which, like,
you're kind of, like, kind of snooty intellectual,
which I respect, but, like, that's fine.
Speaker 1: And this is because I'm an Aquarius,
you're saying?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: So essentially you're saying that
the perceived but possibly inaccurate positions
of stars and planets at the time of
my birth determine my personality.
Speaker 4: Well.
Speaker 3: I guess you don't have time, but I
will start screwing up this astrology. Absolutely.
We also we're looking for work permits, buy this
crap. So I'm only rising from a saturation because
my people think I'm a Leo. Just like some kind of
coincidence. But I will process this because
I'm a Libra rising. Only Aries men have ever
tried it really hard of me, right? Like Pisces
dudes I've been with before. But the same areas.
Men have tried it super hard. Me because of me.
Speaker 1: Excuse me, I just. I just. Let me ask.
We'll end on this note, okay? I want a yes or no.
And let me ask the full question. Is that okay?
Speaker 3: Okay. Right.
Speaker 1: Is your belief that the perceived
but possibly inaccurate determination about the
position of stars and planets at the time of my
birth dictates my personality today, yes or no?
Speaker 3: Absolutely.
Speaker 4: All right.
Speaker 1: There you go. Aubrey from Wisconsin,
great to hear from you.
Speaker 3: Bye.
Speaker 1: Hi there. Is Aubrey
from Wisconsin. I can't think
of any better note than that to end
on. Thank you to everyone who called
in. We will take calls again if I have
anything to say about it, if they let me.